&gt;&gt; A few minutes ago, I showed you the graph of y equals negative 1 8th times x
minus 4 times x minus 24. Now this time I've graphed a graph that looks pretty
similar to that. I just changed this to a 28 instead. Anyway I'd like you to
inspect this graph that we have now. Now while your'e looking at this graph, I'd
like you to think back to the first parabola we dealt with in this lesson. Y
equals negative x squared over 8, plus 4 x, X minus 14. Remember, this was the
curve that we were using to describe how the ball would fly out of the slingshot
and go through the hoop at Grant's display booth. For this quadratic equation,
we found it's y-intercept, it's x-intercepts and it's maximum, as these points
right here. Take a second and compare these points to this graph, and then think
about how these equations might be connected. Here are a few different options
for how these two equations might be connected to one another. And I'd like you
to pick all of the ones that apply. Is there no connection between them at all?
Do their graphs share a few points? Do their graphs go through all of the same
point? Do they graph the same curve? Or are the equations equivalent to one
another?